okay so i can take my get my revenge
against mmv Bob I got 20 saying a nice
guy that's not really right let's see I
can do better this time here
yeah some sideline of the Bogle I got an
e5 that's good wow it's not very
exciting okay well I think it's more
often easiest to just take that take
that night before he gets in 94 okay I
think I'm taking okay well I can just
develop what take it's a pretty pretty
even position those captures only five
never really net wide that much
okay let's take that right what's no
intended sacrifice can also take the
damn rope them why not
so just in exchange essentially okay to
wear what is why i doing next Queenie
for or something I think I will shoot
for Bishop e7 yeah that he will take
rootin ok cannot go f six so I have five
and so cover cover the pot for the
moment
okay so it's not not exactly easy the
bishop there is strong the dark squared
bishop is strong we should be seven even
move the bishop bag today for something
and rook c8 it's not easy to win and not
at all
submission a five
that's not easy but easy at all
the sea pony has allocated pretty
reliably if I go back it's going back
going to see two hmm but on d3 the
bishop is also not doing much and now
that doesn't really help putting it on
d3
yeah the bad thing is that it's actually
relatively easy for y to play he just
stays and push us this a and B porn
should be seven was a threat
trading the happy ships would be good
LightSquared bishop it's very very
directly played I'm very directly
straightforwardly plate now I don't
think I can win this I mean I would love
to win because I have zero points
against this person and it's not great
if you are the clearly better player on
paper but I have to have to just take
this position and be okay with it
anything I can try to do at least
getting the bishop around somewhere
time morning
okay come on let's let's play this
completely dry shiver opposite colors
ending bra alfred bra alfred bra our
third game plan yeah couldn't do much
there when he blundered the exchange but
the resulting position wasn't wasn't
clear it just wasn't clear here this is
this kind of thing I mean would it was
clear as the wrong way to put it it's
just it's just not easy at all to play
this position I should somehow try to
not lose the e5 pawn this this was
already the problem I think here that is
completely okay for white yes this is an
excellent coordination of pieces the
bishop is covering everything now I have
no winning chances here whatsoever now
that's an arcade roll not much to do I
would you would like to win but no
chance then even the extra exchange
didn't help it was a super solid
position for him okay thanks for
watching